hello how y'all doing ready the talks
have been fantastic I'm super happy that
I was actually able to get here as my
first Cascadia J s been meaning to come
for a couple of years it's been
absolutely phenomenal unfortunately
after the talk I'm gonna have to walk
off the stage and right out to the lift
the airport I'm gonna miss the party
tonight I hope you all have fun it's
something an absolute blast
so I'm James J a snow online pretty much
everywhere it's whitter github
you've gmail you know feel free to reach
out anytime if you want to talk about
node we're contributing to open source I
work for these folks there are a company
headquartered on the southern coast of
Ireland a tiny little village you would
have no idea that there was an
international software company there
there's about a hundred and thirty of us
spread about over 24 countries they pay
me to work on node full-time my
literally on the platform itself and I
also manage the consulting team there so
not only do I get to build node I get to
help go out and teach people how to use
it and how to use it better so it you
know it's really exciting for me because
you know I get to see every day they the
really amazing things that people are
using node for but I also get to see the
kind of the misconceptions or the
mistakes that are made not from the
fault you know from the engineering
teams faults but largely due to
misconceptions of the programming
language or things that we did not
communicate properly about the platform
how it works and there's a lot of
misconception out there about how the
node internals actually function for the
past probably a year whenever a customer
comes to our team and they're saying
well our node app is kind of slow we
need to figure out why my first question
is are you using promises and if they
say yeah my first response is you're
using them wrong because typically folks
are actually using them wrong and it's
and it's not their fault it's just the
promise abstraction there are some
nuances about it
how it interacts with node and the event
loop and things like next tick and
timers and you know all these you know
different things that can really trip
some folks up so I'm here to talk a
little bit about you know how all this
stuff comes together so a lot of people
see node pen like this some people think
it's a toy right I can just look at this
for four hours I have like three of
these at home you know but you know it's
like you look at it it's like okay
what's happening inside I'm flipping a
switch something's happening but I don't
quite know what's there so we're gonna
my talk about how we can peer in what's
going on and I'm gonna talk about Hell
note itself functions under the covers
with regards to the event loop so what's
happening inside this may be a little
bit hard to read but this code prints a
series of console statements to the
console right your challenge is to
figure out without running the code
right now have a link where you can go
out and running it try to figure out the
order in which these statements are
printed there are a couple promises in
here there is a set immediate there's a
next tick this new thing called cue
micro test because we didn't have things
confusing enough set timeouts does it
promise all it's a lot going on in this
thing so it can be rather difficult to
see what is happening these are pretty
much all the ways of scheduling a
synchronous activity within node alright
so we have promised we have event
emitter been meters been in there from
you know almost the beginning async
await which I absolutely love next tick
and set immediate which you know they
actually should have been reversed in
the names the one missing from here is
like set interval and cue micro tasks is
this one we just added a couple weeks
ago it is similar to promises you know
when you do a problem a promise then
right it does the same kind of task
where you can kind of manually at a at
an item there that only works right now
node in master alright so if you're
building from the master or node 11 so
if you you know if you try out this code
you know date or node 10 you just have
two comments out that Q micro test line
they're right in the middle well I said
you challenged you just you can go ahead
and read this if you want to write that
down so look at the code see if we can
figure it out if anybody do figure out
the order you know without actually
running the codes let me know because I
only know of a couple of people within
note and within another project itself
they could figure it out on the first
try uh but in order to figure out that
you know to see what this code is doing
in order to be able to reason about it
there are four critical concepts we need
to know the first one is the event what
it is basically how it works
the next one is the next tick Q alright
this is the thing that the process next
tick function interacts with the third
one is two micro tasks you write this is
the thing that promises interact with
and the fourth is this concept there's
no such thing as asynchronous JavaScript
it does not exist
all right you can schedule the execution
of eight of JavaScript asynchronously
but you cannot run JavaScript
asynchronously all right very very
important concept when it comes to
understanding what's happening within a
node process and how that is performing
so this might be a picture you've seen
before it's a very abstract view of the
event loop all right it's this thing you
know it turns around and around and does
stuff right but what exactly is it doing
this is you know this is a better view
in my opinion well the event loop does
is essentially delivering messages right
so you can imagine you know I'm a letter
carrier right and I have a stack of
letters right but I need to deliver so I
have one right now I'm gonna give it to
somebody and I can't just go and to the
next person in Port handing letters out
what I have to do is when I give it to
somebody I have to wait
until they do whatever they're gonna do
with it right they read it they figure
out you know what response they're gonna
give they write out a response right and
then and then they tell me that they're
done okay
so then I go to the next person and I
can hand them their letter and then I
have to wait all right and then I go to
the next person and hand them theirs
that is what the event loop does it
takes a queue of messages so cute you
know we're callbacks right events that
have occurred and it goes through and
hands those off to JavaScript functions
to execute all right it can only do one
of these at a time all right
one of the really important concepts to
understand is that in node you have a
call stack so you have the event loop
running down here you have some C++ code
and then you have some JavaScript code
right every time the event loop gets a
notification it's gonna call through C++
up to the JavaScript all right and then
when that JavaScript returns back all
the way down to the event loop you can
move on to the next task and run the
next stack of JavaScript code okay now
this is critically important because
over here on the side are these two
little things here one is the next tick
Q and the other is the micro task you
when code is running in JavaScript and
you call process next tick it's just
going to drop a function into that X to
Q and leave it there when you schedule a
problem when you call a promise and
interview in resolves to the dot dot
then or dot catch or dot finally what's
gonna happen is that function handler is
gonna be dropped into micro test queue
and it's left there okay it's not until
the threat of execution we you know that
stack unwinds back to that JavaScript
C++ layer that that next took cue and
the micro task queue is drained so all
of those functions will not be called
until control returns back to the c++
layer
you know from that from that call okay
so we can only execute one task at a
time all of these tell you know these
asynchronous tasks that are scheduled to
get an end up getting queued in the
micro task queue or the or the next two
queue unless they're a timer which works
entirely different timer will run on the
event loop either on the next turn or
some you know set of milliseconds or
seconds out yeah you know as the event
loop turns but still as you're going
through and doing all the scheduling it
still only runs one thing at a time
so when javascript is running the event
loop is not the event would pass the
pause whatever you are whatever it's
executor in his code which means you
can't collect i/o events no network
traffic is being okay no network
connections are being are being
processed
it's just executing that code we call
this event loop delay and it's the
single most important concept for node
performance all right this is the thing
that will kill your node node
applications from from running so this
is an example you know whenever you're
doing any kind of large synchronous
activity right you're just killing
everything you're killing performance
you're not laying node do it do what it
does which is asynchronous i/o okay so
again javascript is not synchronous
there's a trick question had to leave it
a little you know a trick question
because the answer should be obvious
it's very the fact that I'm asking it
the answer is no not all javascript in
node runs within the event loop and this
comes as a big surprise for a lot of
people now here's another question does
it all run within the same event loop as
of no ten no it does not we now have
proper worker threads every worker
thread has its own event loop and node
instance running this is all running
within a single process I'm not gonna
get into that now but it makes things
significantly more complicated but a
hell of a lot more fun so this is gonna
be a blast working with with this
hopefully workers will come out of
experimental by node 12 and you know
yeah I can't wait but there are three
main phases to node startup
there's the bootstrap there's main any
bet blue
you know folks have some different names
for these things what happens during
boot strap is nodes loading its own
JavaScript right who's doing serverless
stuff all right all right who have had
problems with cold start times
that's because node is damn slow at
loading itself it has a whole bunch of
JavaScript that it needs to load and
then it needs to load the user code on
top of that right which is which happens
during main during this time it's
loading at all it's [ __ ] parsing the the
JavaScript it's compiling it and then
executing it and there's a lot of boot
up that needs to happen within node
itself to to make sure that it's that
it's able to run the event loop is
started after main scope exits all right
and only if asynchronous tasks were
scheduled so this is an example so we
have this bootstrap budgies file and one
of the statements here is this console
log right we have the performance API
this no timing object gives you some
time stand to when things within node
kicked off or when they when they
completed this loop start tells you when
the event loops was actually started
after that yeah after your code it
started running so in bootstrap j/s here
this first console log statement loop
start is gonna be -1 which indicates
that the loop has not actually started
you schedule some asynchronous
activities set immediate when that runs
you check loop start again and you'll
see an actual timestamp there so this
initial code this top scope right
top-level scope this is running within
that main scope right at this point the
event loop is not running why is this
important in this code if you want to
start reasoning about what this is doing
and the order of execution you have to
start thinking about what is running
within the event loop and what is not
running within the event loop you also
have to start thinking about what is
running within the micro task queue what
is running within the process next to
what is a timer and how all of these
things are relate to one another
it is extremely complicated to visualize
even conceptually how these things
interact with one another we've
fortunately we built some tools to
figure that to start to visualize this
so the first rule of no J's performance
no when your code is running no yeah no
no each individual function so the first
tool that we've that we have within
those are trace events trace events are
a file format that that came out of v8
and Chrome it's a right now it's a JSON
format that gets outputted by the engine
and by node whenever significant events
happen within the core we have to go
through and actually implement the code
to emit these we are in the process now
of expanding the types of information
that can come out of node through trace
events one of the key bits of
information we can get right now is what
a synchronous activity is happening over
the lifetime of that of that application
we can use this I will show in just a
minute to visualize the activity
happening with the Met application the
next important tool with async Kooks
this is the low-level API which is what
we use to actually emit the trace events
so you know just see what is happening
so whenever a new object is created
whenever a callback is invoked the async
hooks API is called this third one it's
not actually in core it's another tool
it's a it's an external tool they my
team a new form in your form built it's
all open source called bubble bubble
bubble pop bubble profiling I'll show
you how this works and how it relates to
all this but it's built on top of of
trace events so the first thing I pick
until we have is built into chrome
itself this is the chrome trace view
it's a very unassuming simple UI maybe a
little bit hard to read because of the
colors that are there but it can read
this JSON file
that is emitted by the node process in
by v8 and depending on what categories
of trace events you you you got it to
emit you pull this in and it gives you a
timeline of when those things were
occurring so this is looking at that
timing
file and we see that there was an
immediate scheduled right that was the
said immediate that we had and that is a
persistent object to exist over time
right and then at some point that gets
executed we have two of those that are
happening here we have multiple promises
and this will show you the entire
lifecycle of these of these things we
have within nodes these things called
tick objects those are the next tick
things they're scheduled on that queue
we can also see when v8 was actually
executing code and the interesting thing
about this is we can actually if we
drill in and see zoom in on this you see
it actually gets fairly complicated we
can see the exact transition points when
v8 to go you know when v8 is done
executing the JavaScript code and when
control returns back to that c++ layer
and things like the next tick queue and
the micro task queue get executed this
is extremely helpful if you know what a
synchronous activity your application is
scheduling for you to know what the
actual performance impact of that code
is you can see those transition points
you can see when this you know this big
json.parse thing you might have in there
you know how long how much time that's
taking up and what else
it is delaying now it takes a bit of
practice to figure out what you know
what's going on in here
and it's not the best use of our
interface it is evolving over time but
it's extremely useful to see see these
transition points all right so let's go
back here
bootstrap trace events something we
enabled in in core if you use this
command line you can see let's see here
you can see exactly when node itself
executes its various bootstrap phases so
when it when does it start the event
loop when is it compiling its own code
those kind of things so we're going to
set up some categories we're gonna do v8
we're gonna go node VM and we're gonna
say node bootstrap and I mean look at
that
the but I don't want to give away the
order of it alright so there we have it
we can come back in here look at our
node trace file and we can see in here
there's a bug in Windows it's not
actually telling me what it should say
under this context context apply script
and it should tell me the exact file
names that I was requiring and that's
nodes own library and your code that's
running and here it'll tell you when it
was required it will tell you exactly
how long it take to load it how long it
took to compile it and how long it took
to execute it and then show you the
exact ordering of the loading of your
dependencies over time and you can you
know if you look at that with the async
activity information turned on you can
also see that activity occurring
relative to turns of the event loop so
you can see exactly when all of your
your code is being run and exactly how
long it took it took dacing trace events
this is the thing that takes the async
hooks information and exports it out to
the to that trace event logs and this
gets quite a bit more complicated so if
we want to take the same one and we're
gonna say node async hooks this is this
all of this is just built into the node
binary right now works for 10 and 11
there's some support in it for 8 there
are some bugs in it so everybody should
be on 10 anyway so upgrade alright so
we're gonna run this again we're gonna
come back here load this back up and in
here we see there's you know quite a bit
more detail this is where we're seeing
all of those promise objects the
immediate stew timers the next kicks and
and we can see the execution of these
things relative to one another
all right the the trees Event Viewer
is good it provides a lot of detail it's
really hard to process if you have an
extremely complicated application just
this last week I was you know at a
customer we you know in 8 1
and I think was a twenty second
benchmark of their code we ran through
and they ended up just in that 20
seconds they had created something like
fifteen thousand promises about ten
thousand next tix and a whole bunch else
the the the trace event file was massive
and it just killed chrome when I tried
to load the you know loaded in the
viewer it's extremely complicated and
there's a lot of data that's there so we
needed a different way of viewing it so
we created a tool called clinic this is
all open source you can get it from you
know yeah NPM from clinic use yarn
whatever and what it is designed to do
is help you diagnose performance
problems within your application bubble
props is one of the tools here and it's
very simple clinic bubble node again I
don't want to give away the result we're
gonna let it do its thing for a few
minutes what it's doing right now is
this exporting that vet file and then
it's going to go through and actually
analyze the all of that async activity
and then it's going to give you a
display of that asynchronous activity
what this is showing you is the
aggregate latency caused by a
synchronous activity within Europe and
within your application you can explore
this you can kind of drill down into it
you can see exactly what promise has
happened the UI we're still working on
it some application you know some of
them turn out we have a whole gallery of
a really crazy artwork from this thing
but what it's basically showing you is
how long it took to transition from one
asynchronous activity within your code
to another so where's the trace event
you can see or see it over a time line
right you can see to the transition
points what this is going to do is
aggregate those and show you exactly how
much time in each part of your
application node was spending and notice
doing work right or how much time it was
spending waiting for work to be done
okay so let me show you let me ask you
this one our promise is asynchronous
it is a trick question
do you promise his execute concurrently
there's a lot of confusion about this I
had an argument with a guy a couple
months ago who is just absolutely
adamant that promise all executed
everything concurrently the challenge is
it doesn't alright when you have an
async function right and that async
function wraps purely synchronous code
right then it's then it's just gonna
execute synchronously so when you have
this promise that all food and bar who's
gonna run completely bars gonna run
completely after it all right what about
promise race same thing race is that
race says whichever one finishes first
give me that all right well if if the
async functions here are all purely
synchronous you're gonna have the exact
same effect foo which is a much longer
loop it's gonna block the event loop
that's gonna finish first and so in this
particular case race is not doing you
any good now if those functions actually
have a synchronous activity like this a
wait time out then yes bar will finish
first and you know in the promise race
will do what you expect it to do all
right running out of time so I'm gonna
skip ahead I want to show you this
example we're quick so this is a
real-world example from an application
we profile just about a week ago
all right using bubble prophesy this is
the high level asynchronous activity
happening in this application it's a
mess because this was very poorly
written code and we can drill down in
here and we can see well yep there's
more activity here let's see we can find
there's some promise chains in here like
deep promise chains this this is the
code that was creating about ten
thousand promises within a twenty second
run this is the one I was looking for
this is extremely poorly written
scheduling code all this is doing is
scheduling that this was about a
thousand promises in a single
synchronous loop and then they weren't
allowed to execute and then as soon as
the the control returned all that
executed all at once
you know one or the other and then each
of those were
also scheduling promises I could drill
down here many more levels I'm have time
to do that but the point is you know in
order to be able to visualize and reason
about this stuff I mean you know the
whole reason this is such a mess is the
team forgot to think about when their
code is being executed they were
wrapping synchronous code with promises
thinking that that you know by
sprinkling a little you know promise
magic everything was going to be
asynchronous or they're using it for
convenience right you know hey if we
using promises one place we have to use
promises everywhere that is a
misconception about promises and if you
continually abuse promises that way then
your code is just going to get slower
and slower and slower because of the
additional allocations of promise these
objects and all these async up resources
and all this scheduling overhead doesn't
mean that your synchronous code is going
to run any faster okay so that's that's
it because I just wanted to kind of peel
and I'll peel back to hurt a little bit
how the event loop runs how these things
work together and some of the tools you
can use to start visualizing this stuff
feel free
reach out set them J a snow anywhere if
you want to talk about some of this
stuff need some more pointers on kind of
how these things are going or you know
how to make your node applications
faster just reach out and let me know
thanks
[Applause]